This big election just
happened in Taiwan.
China, of course, is freaking out
because China thinks that Taiwan
should be theirs.
Some in Taiwan are actually flirting
with the idea of declaring independence,
And in the middle of all of this,
the United States has made the decision
to send
a bunch of American officials to Taiwan,
which is
the exact thing
they know will just make China
really mad.
The United States has to walk
this really weird,
ambiguous line with Taiwan.
On one hand,
they're like required
to give them weapons
and like by law, saying
that they will support their security.
But on the other hand,
they don't actually technically
recognize Taiwan as a country.
that everyone's asking is
“would the United States intervene
if China invaded Taiwan?”
No one really knows.
So Biden
sending American officials
to Taiwan right after the election
is just a way of the U.S.
kind of saying,
“Hey, we're still here, we support you.”
And in the process,
they're poking China
and straining
these relations
that have started to become
a little bit better.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.